i thought i would wander into a bit of a
minefield and talk about lift and what
causes lift in airplanes and there are
several
entirely erroneous or partially
erroneous explanations and actually very
few entirely correct explanations
actually because it's quite complicated
well how do we know yours is going to be
right
it probably won't actually in its
entirety but probably shouldn't say that
on video all right all right where do
you want to start maybe we should start
with some of the wrong explanations so
the classically wrong explanation
invokes a thing called the bernoulli
effect and says okay so you've got your
aerofoil and it's flying through the air
but let's think of things in the
reference frame of the aerofoil so we'll
have that stationary in the air
streaming past it and the classic
explanation has the air going above and
below the wing and kind of joining up
when he gets around the other side and
of course there's more air kind of going
higher and lower as well
and the classically wrong explanation
says so the air going over the aerofoil
has further to go than the air going
under the aerofoil so in order to meet
up with the air at the other end it has
to travel faster and then there's this
thing called the bennui effect that
basically says that when air is
traveling faster its pressure decreases
and that's really just the conservation
of energy that's really just saying that
the energy of the air molecules is
partly in random motion which creates
pressure partly in the streaming motion
and in order to conserve energy if you
increase the amount of streaming energy
you decrease the amount of pressure
energy so the pressure up here because
this air's got further to go than this
air it's travelling faster pressure is
reduced therefore the pressure above the
wing is lower than the pressure below
the wing pressure is just the force per
unit area that means that actually the
the force above the wing pushing down on
the wing is less than the force below
pushing up and therefore i think it
rises which all sounds very plausible
but the benue effect is a real thing yes
is that not the bernoulli effect you
just described that is the banui effect
i just described there are at least two
flaws with this argument the fundamental
one that i kind of slipped in there
is saying that the air meets up on the
far end so there's no reason why you
know when the air leaves from this end
it doesn't kind of make an agreement
with its pal here that it's going to
meet up when it gets to the other end
there is no reason why the air
travelling above should get the far end
at the same time as the air travelling
below in fact the air travelling above
travels so much faster that it gets
there before the air traveling below in
reality so that's the first fallacious
part of the argument is that it has to
travel faster to meet up with its friend
at the far side of the journey past the
airfoil but professor if you just said
that in fact it gets there fast doesn't
that mean we get like a hyper banui
effect you actually get more lift than
that naive argument would predict so
there's a second argument which is
sometimes put forward about why this
can't be the explanation and this one's
not quite so true and the argument goes
that if it were true
then it wouldn't be possible for an
airplane to fly upside down which of
course they can yes so here's our
airplane is our airplane flying upside
down if the previous argument was true
which to some extent it is if this
airplane would just fly straight into
the ground because the lift effect we
were talking about before is now pulling
it in this direction instead of that
direction but of course the pilot has
other things that they can alter and in
particular they can move the nose of the
plane up and down which has the effect
of moving the wing and by changing the
angle of attack with the wing like this
the airflow we were talking about before
there's something called the stagnation
point which is the point at which the
air kind of splits between either going
above the wing or below the wing and the
stagnation point as you change the angle
of attack in this way moves downwards
the previous argument still sort of
holds because actually the air going
above the aerofoil is still going
further than the air going below the
aerofoil so the bennui type effects that
we were talking about before we still
occur so the other argument goes that
actually even when you're flying the
right way up you have a bit of an angle
of attack so the way you really fly an
airplane is with the aerofoil slightly
tilted and the argument goes that the
air essentially just bounces off the
underside of the wing and heads on down
this way and you can see that the the
air molecules through this process have
acquired a momentum downwards and that
means that the air foil will acquire a
momentum upwards just from conservation
of momentum there the plane's just being
battered into the air it is it's been
pushed up by air bashing into it
there are a couple of reasons why this
is wrong what happens on the upper side
of the airflow remember is that the air
goes over and actually also ends up
being bent downwards the air traveling
over the top of the wing by acquiring
downwards momentum means that it has to
be transferring upwards momentum to the
wing as well and so in fact the air
travelling over the wing is also
contributing to the left it actually
contributes more of the lift than the
air going underneath the aerofoil it
really comes down to the fact that you
can't really think about a gas like air
as just a load of little ping pong balls
one easy way to think about that is if
you were to hold your hands up in front
of your face and blow against it
the air actually hits your hand and then
shoots out to the sides now if you were
just throwing ping pong balls at the
wall that would never happen right they
would just bounce straight back at you
and it really is because air as a gas
behaves in a very different way from a
collection of individual particles you
have to worry about the interactions
between the particles as well
which means that these kind of simple
momentum conservation
ideas about how an era blank and fly
can't be the whole story
how does an airplane fly
okay
so
the
physics for this sort of goes back to
leonard euler in the 18th century
who came up with a set of things called
the euler equations and the euler
equations you can write them down
mathematically it's all quite
complicated but actually physically what
they're saying is that as air moves
around there are three conserved
quantities you need to worry about the
masses conserve which it just says that
molecules don't appear and disappear
that they have to kind of flow
continuously so you have conservation of
mass
momentum is conserved just from newton's
laws and which kind of goes to one of
those slightly spurious explanations we
were looking at and energy is conserved
which of course is where the banui law
comes from and you need to conserve all
three things at the same time and that's
why neither of those previous
explanations can be the whole story
because each kind of borrows bits of the
physics but doesn't do the whole thing
at the same time the way these three
things behave together is really quite
complicated which is why you get these
complicated flow patterns around wings
like this and you have to start worrying
about effects like turbulence and those
kinds of things although each of those
previous arguments kind of capture some
aspect to what's going on you really
need to think about all three of them at
the same time and actually if you really
want to do things properly you have to
worry about viscosity effects that if
you've got one load of air travelling at
a particular speed it'll tend to drag
the next lot of air along at a similar
speed it's very hard to have one lot of
air going very quickly and the other lot
not moving at all so you have these
viscosity effects that air kind of drags
other bits of air around and if you want
to put that in as well then you have to
take the euler equations and add this
viscosity effect and then you end up
with a thing called the navier-stokes
equations which were only invented in
the 19th century which are the full set
of equations you really need to solve to
understand what's going on with that
what is going on there so okay so
remember we're trying to do these three
aspects and really we you know you need
to do conservation of mass conservation
of momentum and conservation of energy
all at the same time so here's what's
going on here's our wing the air above
is kind of being squeezed together it's
a little complicated to figure out
exactly why just because you know if
there were a wall up here it would kind
of make sense that actually suddenly
it's being pushed into this narrower
space and everything's being squeezed
together but there isn't there's just a
whole lot more air up there but again it
just comes out of the equations that the
air ends up being squeezed in this way
because it's being squeezed into a
tighter space but you've got the same
amount of air remember the first of
things we have to conserve is mass to
get the same amount of air through but
in this squeeze region instead of this
sort of wider region it has to travel
faster so the air is indeed traveling
faster above the wing than it is below
the wing so that part is true not
because it has to go further just
because the geometry of the obstruction
here squeezes the air together it really
is just the way the air flows around an
obstruction like this so it is traveling
faster so that's the conservation of
mass the air here is compressed which
means it's traveling faster which means
benue's law conservation of energy says
that the pressure here is lower which
means the force downwards on the top of
the wing is less than the force upwards
and therefore that's the phenomenon of
lift but then the last part and if you
think about it the gas originally all
flowed in like this and by the end it's
all flowing downwards like this
so that the air has indeed acquired a
downwards momentum and we have to
conserve momentum you know if the air is
now flowing downwards being pushed
downwards that means the the wing is
pushed upwards and so you can indeed
think of this globally as a
conservational momentum effect that the
air globally acquires downwards momentum
due to these various phenomena we've
just been talking about which means that
the wing acquires an upwards momentum so
you can see all three of the aspects all
feed into the explanation the
conservation of a mass the conservation
of energy and the conservation of
momentum
and really you can't extricate any one
of them and say that's the reason why
you really have to think about all three
at the same time in order to understand
the global phenomenon
between the bernoulli one and the
conservation of momentum one which one
is more important which like
i don't think you can separate it out in
that way i think you really have to
think about all three at the same time
because the physics equations you are
solving really are solving for all three
of these things at the same time and if
you were to fiddle with one of them that
would affect the others
so actually you can't say lift is being
caused by conservation of momentum or
lift is being caused by conservation of
energy through the bernoulli effect it
really is the combination of both of
them together with the conservation of
mass which is causing the effect
well i guess the last thing to say is
that reality is always more complicated
than any of these simple explanations
and actually if you really want to
design a wing you have to do very
complicated hydrodynamic simulations in
three dimensions because this is not a
real wing right in fact you know this is
just a piece of cardboard and actually
real wings are fundamentally
three-dimensional entities and so for
example one of the other aspects you
have to worry about with a real wing is
that it has an end and at the end of it
you have all sorts of effects like
vortices being shed off the end of the
wing and what have you which actually
have a significant effect on the lift of
the wing as well so although as a
physicist this is the explanation if you
want the engineer's explanation
as to how a wing works you really have
to give an even more complicated story
i mean you showed me a bunch of things
at the start that you described as like
the fallacies and yeah a lot of it ended
up being part of the final explanation
so it felt like those fallacies were
okay there was just other things at play
as well that's true i think that's a
fair reflection that actually you know i
would refer to them as fallacies but
they i guess partial truths would
probably be a better explanation for
them so banui effect does make planes
fly booner effect does make planes fly
so does conservation of momentum so in
some sense everyone's right so maybe
everyone should be
happy so i've gone over there some water
which i'll go and collect and we'll go
another 20 paces that way and show you
that the water will extend the range
even further